[Musik]
wir haben keinen Stromproblem so hat es
uns allen der Wirtschaftsminister gesagt
noch vor kurzem doch wir haben
stromproblemen diese Woche drohen erste
Notabschaltung weil der Strom in
Deutschland verdammt knapp wird und
Millionen Deutsche haben noch ein ganz
anderes Stromproblem nämlich den Preis
der explodiert der große stromabzocke
der Konzerne darüber diskutieren wir
jetzt in dieser Runde schönen guten
Abend nämlich an bei uns den
Energiemanager bei nbw war er der Chef
auch bei uns Heiko von Tisch schwitzen
ganz andere Energie Manager Ökostrom
Anbieter Lichtblick den hat er gegründet
und hat ein Ökos Thriller jetzt
geschrieben mit dem Titel die Welt kippt
Ursula Engel in Käfer Vizepräsidentin
des sozial fand Verbands Deutschland ist
bei uns Florian Tonka Lindners
Staatssekretär zuständig unter anderem
für die Finanzhilfen die uns jetzt alle
entlasten sollen in Deutschland und
Ramona Ball und Verbraucher Schützerin
sie kennt die stromnöte von uns allen
deutschen ganz genau in allen schönen
schönen Abend der Frau ballert wir haben
in diesen Tagen gehört von dem Beispiel
aus Niedersachsen in Ammerland da hat
eine Familie begonnen mit dem Grill zu
heizen zu Hause was erstmal witzig
klingt ist tragisch geendet die mussten
alle ins Krankenhaus mit der CO2
Vergiftung wie verzweifelt muss man sein
wenn man zu solchen Mitteln greift
ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt nur
verzweifelt ist das ist tatsächlich auch
ein bisschen unwissend weil
wahrscheinlich ist es teurer als wenn
sie doch richtig heizen würden seitdem
der Gas oder Strom ist natürlich
abgestellt also ja aber den Leuten gibt
es bei vielen Leuten gibt es eine
Verzweiflung die rufen bei uns an und
sagen ich komme nicht mehr klar die
Abschläge sind so hoch man muss dazu
sagen ganz vielen Fällen kann man da
rechtlich tatsächlich auch was dagegen
machen denn die die jetzt über 1 € zum
Beispiel springen im Strompreis das sind
unseriöse Anbieter die ist mit dem Recht
auch nicht so richtig handhaben und da
schreiben wir natürlich dagegen ein
Esel gleich noch mal ganz genau auf auch
wie sie sich zu Hause dann wären können
gegenüber Hütte Stromrechnung aber wir
waren noch mal bei den Gefühlen bei der
Verzweiflung erleben Sie auch Wut in
diesen Tagen eigentlich wir erleben so
ziemlich alles Verzweiflung Scham weil
man selber nicht mehr klar kommt
meint man hätte es selbst verschuldet
das hat man nicht
Wut auf jeden Fall das spüren wir schon
gegen die gegen die Energieversorgung
gegen die Politik gegen jeden teilweise
auch gegen uns weil wir nichts machen
aber wir erleben auch viel
Leute die sagen na ja der Preis ist nun
mal so hoch Energie konnte nicht so
billig sein wie es bisher war also es
gibt viele Leute die verstehen das auch
trotzdem Verständnis irgendwie haben für
die aktuelle Lage alle Menschen haben
not ne ähm also das ist ja ein bisschen
das wird gerade so getan als auch ganz
Deutschland jetzt hier frieren würde und
kein Strom mehr hätte und unter diesen
Preisen echt sind würde es gibt Leute
die können sich das durchaus noch
leisten und die brauchen die ganzen
Beihilfe nicht aber da reden wir
sicherlich auch noch drüber
also es gibt viele Leute die kommen zu
uns und die sagen wir wollen einfach nur
wissen wie machen wir es jetzt richtig
wir wollen das angehen jetzt endlich das
Thema Energie Frau Engel in Käfer wird
in diesem Winter plötzlich zum ja
vielleicht größten Armutsrisiko in
Deutschland
davon bin ich fest überzeugt und ich
sehe vor mir vor den Augen die
alleinerziehende Mutter mit zwei Kindern
die eine Stromsperre hat die also
überhaupt nicht mehr weiß wie sie
zurechtkommen soll die noch nicht mal
mehr in warmen Tee kochen kann in der
Kälte sitzt mit ihren Kindern und der
der Strom abgesperrt wurde weil das
nämlich sehr schnell passiert und
deshalb sind wir ja auch für ein
Moratorium bei der Stromsperre zumindest
bis zu einer bestimmten Einkommensgruppe
ich bin voll davon überzeugt es gibt
Menschen mit Einkommen die da drüber
liegen die das nicht brauchen aber
andere die an der Armutsgrenze sind und
runterfallen also dass der Strom erstmal
weiter fließt dass die Konzerne erstmal
sozusagen Auge zudrücken und in dem
Moment eben nicht an ihren Profit denken
sondern auch an ihre soziale
Verantwortung wer trägt den
Verantwortung in ihren Augen für diese
Fälle für explodierende Strompreise für
die Notlage die Menschen im Moment
geraten weil die Energiepreise
explodieren wer trägt die Verantwortung
wir tragen sie alle und zwar mit der
meine ich die Politik ich meine die
Wirtschaft aber ich meine auch die
Sozialverbände und damit bin ich auch
bei meinem Verband ich sehe schon eine
Verpflichtung und Verantwortung dafür zu
sorgen dass diese Menschen zumindest
leben können wir sind ja wieder wie sie
haben das gesagt in steinzeiten wenn man
sich vorstellt Familien sitzen drei oder
vier Tage in der Totalen Kälte mit
kleinen Kindern die krank werden das ist
doch unwürdig unserer Situation und
deshalb denke ich haben wir alle
Verantwortung dagegen anzugehen und als
ein Sozialverband sehe ich oder als eine
Vizepräsidentin sehe ich meine
Verantwortung darauf aufmerksam zu
machen Verantwortung Wahrsagen sie vor
allen Dingen die Käfer wir sprechen aber
auch über die Verantwortung wie es
überhaupt zu den explodierenden
Energiepreisen kommt ohne zu weit
zurückgehen wenn jetzt die Rechnung auf
dem Tisch kommt ist der Ärger bei ihnen
abzuladen hat Tonka im Finanzministerium
bei ihrem Chef von Lindner oder müssen
wir hier auf die Konzern Fernseher
gucken auf die großen Stromkonzerne in
Deutsch also ich glaube nicht dass es
was bringt wenn man sich jetzt hier
Verantwortung hin und herschiebt wir
haben die schwerste Energiekrise seit
Beginn seit Bestehen dieser Republik das
hat entscheidend mit dem Krieg zu tun
der in der Ukraine geführt wird und bei
dem Energie als Waffe eingesetzt wird in
Deutschland spüren wir aber natürlich in
der Situation die erstmal von außen
kommt durch diesen Krieg dass die
Energiepolitik das letzten Jahrzehnts
mindestens das letzten Jahrzehnts das
ist klar deswegen nur ertrunken nach der
Verantwortung weil das so wahnsinnig
konkret ist man bekommt die
Stromrechnung auf dem Tisch und die
neuen Abschläge auf dem Tisch
möglicherweise sogar Stromsperren jetzt
in vielen Beispielen von den Käfer
schildert das und dann gleichzeitig gibt
es Gewinne bei den Energiekonzern bei
den Stromkonzern ist es einmal ganz
einfach gefragt in diesen Zeiten
eigentlich in Ordnung Profite Profite zu
Profite zu machen also gar nicht anders
denkbar für die Konzern wir haben ja
erstmal nehmen wir Geld in die Hand wie
kaum besonderes Land um die Folgen zu
Bildern wir können niemandem versprechen
dass wir alle Folgen das können wir
nicht das ist in dieser Krise auch nicht
einzuhalten das versprechen wir auch
nicht aber wir bringen die Preise ja
durch die preisbremsen auf ein auf ein
Niveau von dem wir hoffen dass sie dann
auch tragfähig sind wir unterstützen
außerdem auch bedürftige Haushalte noch
direkt aber zu den gewinnen da ist ja
geplant dass wir im Bereich des
Strommarkts besonders hohe Gewinnmargen
die jetzt entstanden sind eben auch
abschöpfen und in die Senkung von
Strompreisen investieren das ist ja Teil
der Gesetze die diese Woche durch den
Bundestag gehen sollen weil weil wir
natürlich erkannt haben dass das auch
nötig ist und dass das auch gebraucht
wird um insgesamt die strompreisbremse
auch bezahlen als Geschäftsmann als
Energiemanager so habe ich sie
vorgestellt Chef von EnBW gewesen würden
sie in dem Moment denken als Manager
Menschen muss sich eine sozialen
Verantwortung gerecht werden gegenüber
den Kunden da muss ich noch mal drüber
nachdenken ob die Stromerhöhung so okay
ist oder geht's tatsächlich am Ende
einfach um den Konzern und ich nehme was
ich kriegen kann also die heutige
strompreisproblematik mal abgesehen
davon dass ich vor 15 Jahren irgendwie
in westbeinfall eben verlassen habe die
heutige strompreisproblematik hat ja
nicht mit EnBW oder einzelnen
Unternehmen zu tun sondern mit einer
jahrzehntelang gewachsenen
energiewirtschaftlichen Struktur in der
wir bestimmte Widersprüche nicht
aufgelöst haben lassen Sie mich eins zu
der Verantwortung sagen wenn ich Frau
Engel und Kiefer und Frau Balut höre
dann tut einem das weh natürlich haben
wir da alle gemeinsam eine Verantwortung
und man fragt sich vor dem Hintergrund
der Diskussion im Sport in den letzten
Wochen wer gibt uns eigentlich das Recht
uns über andere zu erheben in der Welt
wenn wir katalysieren wir nicht wissen
wie wir die eigenen Leute waren durch
den Winter bringen sollen und wenn Frau
Engel einen Käfer jetzt rechts sagt sie
macht sich Sorgen um die Familien die
keine Grundversorgung im Bereich Strom
oder Wärme mehr haben also wer gibt uns
und ist das nicht eigentlich auch ein
Menschenrecht und haben wir dann
eigentlich das Recht uns in der Form
über andere zu erheben die wir übrigens
wirtschaftlich noch brauchen könnten um
einzeln oder oder auch andere
flüssigkeitslieferanten ja wie auch
immer und es macht schon ein sehr
merkwürdiger mit Verlaub in der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister einerseits
sich dort tief verbeugt und wir
andererseits eine gesellschaftliche
Diskussion haben in der wir meinen über
andere richten zu können aber noch nicht
wissen wie wir unsere Probleme reden
auch völlig zurecht und wir müssen auch
über die Konzerne sprechen und meine
Frage war eben ist es in der Zeit
überhaupt in Ordnung Profite zu machen
Gewinne zu machen während andere ihre
Stromrechnung nicht mehr zahlen können
jedes Unternehmen hat auch eine
Verantwortung seinen gesellschaftlichen
Beitrag zu leisten aber die
Fiskalpolitik liegt bei Herrn Tonka und
nicht bei einem Konzern heißt
der Konzern muss erstmal effizient und
vernünftig arbeiten Profit und das was
davon gegebenenfalls Unverteilt wird ist
Aufgabe der fiskan und Sozialpolitik
okay und dafür haben wir ja auch das
privat auf der Politik in unserer Klasse
sagt darf ich einmal noch übersetzen
Profit völlig in Ordnung es muss um die
Gewinne gehen und am Ende führt der
Konzern ja auch Steuern ab und das
fließt dann möglicher allgemeine
glücklicherweise mehr wenn das die
Polizei neben mir ein anderer
Energiemanager Ökostrom Manager Herr von
sie haben Lichtblick gegründet freuen
sich eigentlich demzufolge über jetzt
deutlich steigende Energiepreise das
Energie insgesamt wertiger teurer wird
das glaube ich ist ganz wichtig in der
Tat ja dass wir
endlich
spüren was wirklich Energie für einen
Wert hat und wir dadurch auch angehalten
werden Energie zu sparen und in
Effizienzmaßnahmen
zu zu investieren aber das darf
natürlich nicht dahin gehen dass die
Energiepreise steigen weil über die
Maßen Gewinne erwirtschaftet werden da
würde ich gerne noch mal einen Haken und
ein Wort zu haben Klassen sagen Gewinne
sind vollkommen in Ordnung freie
Marktwirtschaft braucht Unternehmen mit
Gewinnen das geht gar nicht anders aber
was die Politik natürlich jetzt leisten
muss ist das zum einen die sogenannten
übergewinne abgeschöpft werden ja das
also das was auch gesetzlich
regulatorisch völlig falsch gelaufen ist
dass die Produzenten von erneuerbaren
Energien Jahrzehnte lang gefördert
wurden weil ihre Energie zu teuer war
und sie heute bei den hohen
Energiepreisen wahnsinnig viel Geld
verdienen und das alles behalten dürfen
ja damit wurden wurden die Verluste
sozialisiert und sie sind
und das Danken runter weil dazu habe ich
dieses Beispiel hier etwas südlich von
Berlin ist eine Stromrechnung die jetzt
gerade reingekommen ist die ist gut drei
Wochen alt und da ist der neue Abschlag
gekennzeichnet können einmal drauf
gucken hier auf diese Rechnung hier
steht der neue arbeitsspreis 71 Cent
bisher waren da steht dann ganz klein
drunter in dem ansonsten sehr
freundlichen Anschreiben 35 59 das also
der Arbeitspreis der sich mal locker
dort verdoppelt hat das ganze ein
Ökostrom Anbieter derjenige dem diese
Rechnung zugestellt worden ist
der fragt sich der hat sich bewusst für
Ökostrom entschieden warum eigentlich
Wind und Strom ist nicht teurer geworden
in der Zeit die Stromerzeugung ist bei
meinem Ökostromanbieter nicht teurer
geworden ich zahl das Doppelte erklären
das kann man erklären das Licht einfach
daran dass auch die Erzeuger von
windkraft und Solarenergie ihren Strom
im Markt an der Börse verkaufen und
damit den Marktpreis für Ihre Ware
erhalten ja dadurch
seine bewussten Entscheidung für Öko
Ökostrom zahlte im Moment die teuren
Kohlekraftwerke und vor allen Dingen
Gaskraftwerke mit das ist genau der
Punkt den ich eben mit den übergewinnen
meinte ja das darf nicht sein dass die
Erzeuger diese
regenerativen Energie jetzt so
wahnsinnig viel Gewinne machen als als
windford-provence nur weil der der Preis
einer Börse nach oben gegangen ist aber
hier muss genau bei dieser Stromrechnung
die Sie gerade gezeigt haben muss doch
die Politik jetzt reingehen und sagen
wir müssen nicht eine allgemeine
strompreisbremse machen ja von der wie
alle die wir sitzen profitieren ja das
ist natürlich totaler Nonsens sondern
wir müssen den Leuten helfen die
wirklich Probleme kriegen die sich also
ganz konkret zu der Rechnung das ist ja
ein Witz in weiten ganz schlechter Witz
der Strom ist kein Stück teurer geworden
der zahlt aber das Doppelte in Zukunft
an Arbeitspreis Gaspreis beim sie hilft
erstmal im Dezember das stimmt auch in
den Erfolge Monaten oder eine Übernahme
der Abschläge dann die gaspreisbremse
aber danach zahlt da eben dann den
verdoppelten Arbeit ab Januar im
Endeffekt 40 Cent also das dieses
Problem ist das ist natürlich erstmal
eine ganz extrem hohe Arbeitsweise und
hat momentan etwas 45 Cent als Neukunde
oder so der tagesaktuelle Neukundenpreis
aber ganz egal wie der Vertrag aussieht
es wird ab Januar dann im Endergebnis 40
Cent sein für Privatverbraucher was
derzeit auch der auch der Kunde ganz
genau wegen der Strompreis Bremse und
trotzdem müssen wir uns einmal den
Anbieter angucken warum ist das so die
zocken ab in dem Fall der
Ökostromanbieter der produziert
mittlerweile günstig und locker die
Kosten ein die er eigentlich für die
Produktion in dem Gaskraftwerken und
Kohlekraftwerk bekäme ich will ich will
das nicht beurteilen wenn es
Ökostromanbieter gibt die günstiger sind
dann wäre der Wechsel natürlich zu
empfehlen ganz klar das Problem was wir
im Strommarkt haben ist aber nicht so
einfach zu lösen das ist ja im Grunde
dass der Gaspreis und der Strompreis
quasi verheiratet sind ist der Gaspreis
sehr hoch und der hat sich etwas
vervielfacht in eineinhalb Jahren dann
schlägt das auch auf den Strompreis eben
durch weil eben Gaskraftwerke auch zur
Stromerzeugung eingesetzt werden und
dann auch in die Preisberechnung
einfließen und da kommen die sehr sehr
hohen Gewinner her die zum Teil bei Wind
oder Solar entstehen oder auch bei
konventionellen Kraftwerken die wir
allerdings sehr teilweise dann auch
nutzen um den Strompreis an anderer
Stelle zu senken aber das ist ja das
wird ja behandelt das Thema dabei dass
man gesagt ja kann man jetzt machen
nichts bzw hat für die Regierung
übernehmen wir halten Teil natürlich
jetzt staatlich ne ab Dezember und dann
mit der Strompreis Bremse kann ja auch
nicht die Lösung sein Ökostrom Anbieter
verdoppelt man lässig
ich meine Aufgabe diesen Ökostrom
Anbieter hier im Einzelnen zu
kritisieren dass es nämlich zwei Dinge
generell sagen die wenn bestimmte
Unternehmen preislich die aktuelle
Situation ausnutzen ist das schlecht
aber das Grundproblem ist nicht von
Unternehmen im Moment gemacht sondern
dadurch dass wir seit Jahrzehnten und
auch zu Zeiten der Energiewende eine
konsequente in sich inkonsistente
Energiepolitik betreiben in der wir im
Grunde gar nicht mehr wissen was wir
wollen in der wir sagen Kernenergie
wollen wir nicht Steinkohle wollen wir
auch nicht braun Kohle wollen wir auch
nicht dann wollten wir temporär
russisches Gas haben uns völlig
einseitig darauf verlegt und haben jetzt
eine Situation wo wir grundsätzlich
sehen wie gefährlich das ist wenn man
sich in einer einseitige Abhängigkeit
begibt und im Grunde hat die Politik
noch das Glück dass sie Putin
vorschieben kann als den vermeintlich
Schuldigen denn durch die Putin Thema
ist jetzt überhaupt ein Problem virulent
geworden was ist zugrunde liegend sich
über 10 20 wunderbare entwickelt
vertiefen wir gleich genau diese Frage
Herr Klassen letztes Mal zu dem Beispiel
ich fand es eben so irre weil eben es
eine Rechnung ist die sich auf Wind und
Strom bezieht auf irgendwo Energie wo
kommt eigentlich im Moment dieser
Ökostrom wir müssen jetzt gar nicht den
speziellen Anbieter nehmen wo kommt
eigentlich im Moment der Ökostrom her
wir haben seit Wochen nicht besonders
viel Wind in Deutschland und wir haben
seit Wochen zumindest hier in Berlin nur
Sonne ja unabhängig davon woher kommt
sage ich gleich noch was zu noch einen
Satz zu diesem Preis den sie eben
genannt haben ja der Ökostromanbieter
kriegt den Ökostrom auch auf dem Markt
gar nicht billiger ja also insofern von
Abzocke zu sprechen ist nicht korrekt an
dieser Stelle sondern die Gesetze die
die der
regulatorische Rahmen ist so gestrickt
im Moment von der Politik das die
Kilowattstunde Strom ganz egal ob sie
immer Atomkraftwerk erzeugt wurde im
Kohlekraftwerk oder in der
Windkraftanlage gleich viel an der Börse
kostet ja also dieser ökostromhändler
der oft Ökostrom ein und hat gar nicht
die Möglichkeit den Strom billiger zu
und kauft er im Moment überhaupt das war
ja meine Frage Ökostrom ein oder gehst
ja Ökostrom hier bei dem Anbieter und
bei anderen im Moment gar kein ökostein
also davon keine Ahnung ich kenne den
Anbieter nicht aber davon gehe ich nicht
aus die sind ja auch alle zertifiziert
ich glaube schon dass die Ökostrom
Einkaufen das Problem ist dass das
Unternehmen
gebucht habe kriege ich dann in diesen
dunklen Tagen in den Tagen ohne Wind
kriege ich garantiert jeden Tage ja
selbstverständlich nein natürlich ich
glaube dass das bei allen
Ökostromanbietern so ist das Problem
sind gar nicht die Händler sondern das
Problem sind die Erzeuger der
Kilowattstunden ja also die Besitzer der
Solar und Windkraftanlagen die in den
letzten 15 Jahren vom EEG profitiert
haben also eine Förderung bekommen haben
weil sie selber teurer produziert haben
als der Markt ihn vergütet hat und jetzt
hat sich das alles umgedreht ja jetzt
plötzlich sind sie wettbewerbsfähig sind
die günstigste Art Strom zu erzeugen
tatsächlich der Fall ist in Deutschland
die günstigste Art Strom
und die verdienen jetzt wahnsinnig viel
Geld weil das Gesetz eben nicht diesen
Fall berücksichtigt hat damals weil man
überhaupt nie davon ausgegangen ist dass
der Preis mal so in solchen verdienen
wahnsinniges Geld und in dem Fall dieser
Kunde muss wahnsinnig viel Geld
plötzlich draufzahlen was konkret kann
ich machen wenn ich so ein Schreiben
jetzt auf dem Tisch bekomme wie wäre ich
mich kann ich mich wehren überhaupt ich
möchte auch noch mal prinzipiell was
sagen wir stellen das tatsächlich in der
letzten Zeit fest als diese preist diese
Bremse in in so und die Medien gekommen
ist dass die kommen wird
also ich persönlich habe das auch erlebt
ich habe im Anfang November meine
Jahresendabrechnung bekommen auch von
dem Ökostrom Anbieter und da wurde mir
auch gesagt wir können den Preis
konstant halten und die eg-umlage ist ja
auch gefallen klasse jetzt kommen wir
mal richtig zur Geltung und zum ersten
12 kam dann die Erhöhung über knapp über
ist tatsächlich unsere
Vermutung dass da sehr viel
Intransparenz dabei ist
fühlen sie sich da ausgenutzt weil wir
berichten heute hier bei Bild auch über
noch ganz andere Beispiele wattenfall
macht Lockangebote zahlt Prämien um in
die Tarife zu locken und dann knallt am
Ende ein hoher Arbeitspreis rein weil
der Kunde das ja meistens gar nicht
zahlen muss 80 % Federn sie ab und der
das kommt alles vom Staat das heißt Sie
zahlen am Ende die die
Strompreiserhöhung und gar nicht so sehr
erkunde können sich abgezockt nein ich
will mich nicht abgezockt aber es ist
ganz sicher so dass wir sehr genau im
Gasmarkt und dem Strom macht uns ansehen
müssen die verhalten sich die Preise in
Deutschland auch im Vergleich zu anderen
Ländern und wenn es da Auffälligkeiten
gibt dann wird er auch eingeschnitten
werden
Vermutung gewesen ich würde die auch
tatsächlich ernst nehmen also ich will
die nicht aber es ist auch es ist auch
bleiben
Bremse besteht diese diese Preis Bremsen
sind ja so gemacht dass das nur ein
grundkontingent günstiger zu haben ist
und wer gleich viel Strom verbraucht wie
im Vorjahr der Zahl für die letzten 20
Prozent auch den Marktpreis also es ist
ja schon so dass es für den Kunden nicht
egal ist was der Strom kostet oder was
für ein Tarif hat und das ist auch
absichtlich so gemacht worden um genau
diesen Missbrauch möglich
wenn sie so eine Regelung bekommen vom
Staat dann reiben Sie sich doch ja in
vergangenen Zeiten bei EnBW vor 15
Jahren die Hände und sagen na wunderbar
es schade den Kunden nicht höchstens den
Steuerzahlern am Ende dem Kunden aber
erstmal nicht der merkt das gar nicht
ich hole mir das Geld aus dem
Finanzminister
war aber unsere Hauptaufgabe intern
effizienter zu werden und unsere
Hausaufgaben zu machen und nicht
irgendwelche
erlaubt oder missbräuchlichen Preis
Gestaltungspotenzial auszunutzen ich
würde auch bei der Mehrzahl der
Unternehmen das nicht unterstellen zu
Vattenfall kann ich nichts sagen war
mein Wettbewerber ich bin ganz sicher
nicht wattenfall aber es ist ja egal wir
reden ja über die Ziele gar nicht
insofern ist wahrscheinlich dass der der
Schlüssel zur Lösung
Mechanismen finden die jetzt die Not
lindern in einer Form die für die
Unternehmen und auch für Spekulanten
möglichst wenig Missbrauchspotential
schaffen möglichst viel direkt Hilfe und
keine Bürokratiemonster weil am
Bürokratie Monster leidet am Ende der
Staat und der Bürger immer am meisten
und die kniffligen Trickser profitieren
jetzt noch einmal zu der Frage und
gleich auf ein Käfer verballert jetzt
liegt er ja die die Rechnung auf dem
Tisch die neue Abschlagszahlung was
mache ich erstens mal gucke ich ist das
überhaupt möglich dass er den Preis
erhöht habe ich noch einen Festpreis der
hat zwei Jahre ging und ich bin noch ein
Jahr dabei
ist die ist das preiserhöhungsschreiben
ordentlich also ne ist das
wie soll ich das jetzt sagen genügt das
den rechtlichen Vorgaben okay das ist
verdammt schwer zu prüfen ne ja dafür
sind wir ja da das ist ja verbraucherzen
lassen die helfen in dem Fall wenn das
alles so rechtens ist ne dann müsste ich
also erstens mal würde ich mich dann
sofort beschweren beim Kartellamt ne
weil das steht halt immer im Verdacht so
ein bisschen auf 71 Cent Arbeitspreis
das ist schon echt tot auch da hilft die
Verbraucherzentrale weil der sitzt sich
zu Hause im kleinen Häuschen und denkt
ja wie beschwere ich mich beim kartelli
haben wunderbare Internetauftritt mit
mit Musterbrief mit allen möglichen mit
allen Ansprechpartnern und allen Kram ne
also da findet man alles mögliche wir
helfen in der persönlichen Beratung
allerdings sind wir da auch ein bisschen
überfordert und wir freuen uns dann
schon auf nächstes Jahr wenn dann die
Abrechnung mit diesen Bremsen kommen
weil dann wird es ganz lustig ähm und
der der tritt die dritte Möglichkeit ist
natürlich und die vierte also einsparen
das ist mein Spezialisten machen die
allermeisten sowieso schon nein das
machen sie nicht und das vierte wäre
dann tatsächlich eventuell zu einem
anderen Versorger zu gehen aber da
finden sie momentan nur den
Grundversorger sie sagen die Deutschen
sparen noch nicht
wie viel Kilowattstunden verbrauchen sie
im Jahr ich weiß es nicht aber ich weiß
was im Moment alles nicht läuft bei uns
und wo überall das Licht aus ist wo es
vorher anders war die Leute wie viel
Kilowattstunden sie verbrauchen weil das
ist nämlich das allererste um richtig zu
sparen dass man erstmal weiß was
verbrauche ich überhaupt vorher kann man
überhaupt nicht anfangen mit sparen
wollen den Lichtschalter aus und
vergisst das Aquarium was da irgendwie
2000k einen Eindruck ist das schon sehr
sehr viel gespart wird aktuell in
Deutschland vor allen Dingen Käfer haben
sie haben sie eine Grenze wo sie sagen
würden ab da ist eine
Strompreiserhöhung Energiepreis für
Erhöhung unverschämt also ich glaube
dass das in vielen Fällen der Fall ist
und ich würde zu aller erst mal sagen
hier ist die Politik gefordert auch die
Kartell Behörde stärker einzuschalten
wir als Verbraucher haben können das
überhaupt nicht ich nehme die
Abschlagszahlung geht zur
Verbraucherzentrale lass mich da
informieren und die Verbraucherzentrale
muss ich selber erstmal ans Kartellamt
bin aber wo so eine Grenze für sie
erreicht ich würde sagen das kann nicht
sein das kann wo ich meinen
Lebensunterhalt nicht mehr bestreiten
kann ich habe ihn ja eben das Beispiel
erzählt von der alleinerziehende Mutter
mit dem Kindern die tagelang ihren Strom
abgesperrt hatte weil sie weil sie nicht
mehr zahlen konnte und ich weiß es gibt
verschiedene Anregungen was man alles
tun kann wie man auf dem Versorger
zugehen kann wie man Ratenzahlungen
vereinbaren kann aber die Menschen die
nichts in der Tasche haben die können
auch keine Ratenzahlungen machen die
sind drauf angewiesen dass sie irgendwie
Hilfe bekommen und die können auch nicht
selber zum Kartellamt gehen und
nachzuweisen dass das eine Abzocke ist
deshalb ja auch an unsere Anforderungen
an die Politik auch als Sozialverband
diese übergewinde abzuschöpfen und da
sind sie in der Pflicht auch hier die
entsprechende Expertise an den Tag zu
legen das können wir überhaupt nicht das
kann auch kein privater Haushalt das
kann kein allein erzählen
ich weiß nur dass am Ende FDP-Mann
Wirtschaftsminister ist der nein das ist
ein grüner Finanzminister ist ein grüner
es Wirtschaftsminister und beide müssen
sich zusammentun und müssen
entsprechende Voraussetzungen schaffen
ob wir eine das nicht also brauchen ist
vielleicht unglücklich gewählt weil es
geht ja um missbräuchliche Gewinne oder
um Spekulationsgewinne die aus einer
ganz spezifischen Notsituation
resultieren herauskommen ich glaube wenn
man es umdefinieren würde kann man es
für alle einschließlich für die
Unternehmen
verständlicher und akzeptabler machen
denn niemand versteht das Gut
erwirtschaftete Gewinne schlecht sind
aber jeder versteht das missbraucht
nicht oder trickreich erwirtschaftete
Gewinne stärker bescheuert werden was
wir wo wir uns alle einig sind an diese
Kirche wir reden über einen gewaltiges
Strom Problem in Deutschland das obwohl
ein großer Teil der Regierung bis vor
kurzem noch genau das gesagt hat
wir haben einen Wärmeproblem bzw ein
industrieproblem aber kein Stromproblem
und wir haben gerade in Deutschland kein
Stromproblem wir haben ein Wärmeproblem
mit Blick auf diese Atomkraftwerke ist
der Punkt dass sie vor allen Dingen ja
zur Stromerzeugung da sind wir haben
derzeit aber kein Stromproblem sondern
wir haben einen gasproblem das heißt es
ist ja kein Selbstwert zu sagen wir
schließen Kohlekraftwerke oder wir
schließen Atomkraftwerke an sondern man
muss ja sagen warum wollen wir die
eigentlich wieder anschließen wir haben
keinen Strom Probleme Klassen immer
wieder kam das den Sommer hinweg war das
so dumm das zu sagen
scheint nicht zu wissen dass Gas auch zu
Verstromung eingesetzt wird und bei uns
ja in entscheidend im Umfang gerade
durch die letzten produzierte Einheiten
im Sommer war das unverantwortlich war
sach logisch nicht sehr kompetent
vor eigenen Käfer wie viel Menschen
kennen sie dieser Satz der bleibt ja im
Ohr den haben sehr viele Millionen
Deutsche wahrgenommen im Sommer immer
und immer wieder ja gesagt von einem
Teil der Regierung wie ich halte das
viele klug ich halte das nicht für klug
der natürlich wissen wir um die
Zusammenhänge zwischen Gaspreisen und
Strompreisen wir wissen um die
Unzulänglichkeiten der politischen
Rahmenbedingungen dazu wir Wissen darum
dass hin und her geredet wird zwischen
Bundesregierung und EU über die Bremsen
wie die ausgestaltet werden sollen über
die Frage der
übergewinnsteuer ist
Politik können sie helfen warum passiert
sowas
hin und her geschossen warum passiert
sowas warum passiert sowas warum sagt
die Politik ein Teil der Regierung im
Sommer wir haben kein Problem und da
wussten schon Millionen Deutsche Käfer
sagt das auch für sich
ich war auch zum damaligen Zeitpunkt
gegenteiliger Meinung und kann nur sagen
wir haben Laufzeiten der Kernkraftwerke
jetzt über den Winter verlängert und wir
haben eine strompreisbremse die kommt
mit Erlös Abschöpfung das was sie gerade
ja noch mal angesprochen hat also das
zeigt ja
alleine schon das zeigt ja alleine schon
dass wir beim Strom großen
Handlungsbedarf zu sehen
bewusst einmal nach ihrem Kollegen und
Kollegen warum sagt man sowas in der
Politik wieder besseren Wissens und
Gewissens will ich nicht drüber
spekulieren wahrscheinlich
das Thema weil das Thema unangenehm ist
es ging erfahren um die Laufzeiten der
Kernkraftwerke bei den Fragen unter weiß
doch jeder dass sich die Grünen damit
sehr sehr schwer getan haben und ich
vermute da könnte ein Zusammenhang
bestehen aber ich kann es auch nicht
sagen denn ich bin ja nicht bei den
Grünen sondern bei der evangel
Diskussion ganz ehrlich mit sie wissen
alles was im Hintergrund läuft seit wann
wissen Sie denn genau dass Deutschland
ein Stromproblem hat oder eins in diesem
Winter bekommt eine Energiekrise und die
bezieht sich auf alles auf das Strom auf
Heizöl auch jetzt auf Benzin ein
bisschen weniger in den letzten Wochen
aber wir haben im Grunde einen Energie
eine Energie der Krise und da hängt auch
alles mit allem am Ende zusammen und die
Ursachen sind fast immer auch die
gleichen also da würde ich jetzt nichts
ausklammern Kabinettstisch über
Blackouts gesprochen
es ist natürlich so dass wir uns auch im
Kabinett ich bin da nicht jede Woche
dabei immer nur in Vertretung aber das
selbstverständlich über die Sicherheit
der Stromversorgung gesprochen wird und
in der Tat beunruhigt mich auch wenn
Netzbetreiber wie zum Beispiel in
Baden-Württemberg Transnet Nachrichten
verschicken an Stromkunden bitte in der
Stunde nicht verbrauchen oder weniger
brauchen
Finanzministerium ganz konkret einen
Plan für ein Blackout gibt's Generatoren
beispielsweise im Finanzministerium
haben wir keinen Plan für Blackout das
muss das Wirtschaftsminister machen als
Energieministerium wenn das Licht aus
geht wenn der Aufzug nicht mehr fährt
Alter das wir haben uns in der Tat auch
mit den Szenarien auseinandersetzt das
ist ganz klar das ist aber bei uns nun
auch relativ leicht zu lösen denn
schwierig wird es ja da wo Rettungswagen
raus müssen betroffen sind
von der Frage steht ja jeder Haushalt
haben sie Kerzen angeschafft im
Finanzministerium haben sie Generator
der
Finanzministerium angeschafft und wenn
Generator haben weiß ich nicht aber wir
sind natürlich in der Lage auch mobil zu
arbeiten also das ist
haben kommt doch überhaupt keiner mehr
bis in die City rein ich komme gleich zu
ihnen warum warum reden wir gerade diese
Woche oder warum müssen wir gerade diese
Woche so sehr über eine Blackout Gefahr
in Deutschland sprechen wir haben gehört
den Fall hat der Tonka gerade genannt
baden-württembergische Energieversorger
sagen also diese Woche wird es verdammt
eng so ab Mittwoch etwas was dann im
übrigen auch schon übermorgen ist da
fahren wir ab 14 mal lieber ab 14 Uhr
Nachmittag mal lieber ein bisschen
runter ja ich halte die Diskussion über
Blackouts für völlig unangebracht und
für falsch warum weil es keine Blackouts
geben wird in Deutschland ja wir müssen
mal definieren über was wir hier
sprechen sie sprachen gerade von dem
Strom Problem ja und das was die
Politiker gesagt hatten die ja
eingeblendet wurden war das Sprung
Stromproblem das ist mir zu pauschal was
heißt denn das das Stromproblem ja wir
haben alle ein Problem mit dem Preis das
haben wir eben diskutiert das ist ein
riesen Problem für einen Teil unserer
Bevölkerung und diesen Teil der
Bevölkerung nicht allen nicht die
Gießkanne sondern diesem Teil der
Bevölkerung muss die Politik helfen das
ist ein Phänomen mit den hohen Preisen
dass wir nicht auf Dauer haben werden
sondern das haben wir im Moment ja das
ist der einzige darüber haben
jetzt ist sprechen wir über die
Knappheit ja jetzt müssen wir ein
bisschen Begriffe lernen ja es gibt
Blackouts und es gibt Brown Outs ein
Blackout ist ein unkontrollierter
Ausfall eines großen Teils des
Stromnetzes sowas hat es noch nie in
Deutschland gegeben
heraus ein brown-out ist eine
kontrollierte Abschaltung kleinerer
Regionen für eine Stunde oder maximal 90
Minuten was im Voraus im Voraus
kommuniziert wird so entspannten Braunau
na das schalt mal meine Region ab Herr
Glasen ich glaube das also zwei Dinge
erstens die deutschen Stromnetze sind
zwar von ihrer Struktur die stabilsten
auf der erhält weil es ja auch sehr
dezentral sind
gleichwohl kann niemand vorhersagen was
bei bestimmten engpass-situationen
kommen wird weil das System zu komplex
ist zweiter Punkt Brown out sind
natürlich besser als Blackouts aber
fragen Sie mal bei Porsche oder Mercedes
oder VW was die sagen werden
für andere Industrie noch mehr massive
Folgewirkungen haben die ja weit über
den halben Produktionstag hinausreichen
also der die Energiewirtschaft ist das
zentrale nervenschaft und dass wir als
eine der führenden Volkswirtschaften der
Welt das überhaupt heute diskutieren
müssen ist im Grunde erschreckend und
Armutszeugnis peinlich ein Stück weit
sie sagen
guckt euch mal Porsche an wie die
anfangen werden Sie wahrscheinlich na
gut bei Porsche lassen
nein das sage ich überhaupt nicht er
Klassen hat ja recht und natürlich ist
das ein Armutszeugnis das Diskutieren
das liegt natürlich daran dass die
Politik schon zu Schröder Zeiten ja das
war nicht nur Merkel das ist fing schon
bei der SPD an sich viel zu sehr auf
Russland verlassen hat und viel zu sehr
an Russland gebunden hat ja Käfer aber
genauso wie sie aber wir können es nicht
mehr ändern
einigermaßen entspannt da müssen wir
halt einzelne Regionen vom Netz kurz
abhängen oder runterfahren
warum ich das entspannt sage auch ein
brown-out und da sind wir bei wieder bei
den den Zitaten aus der Politik von eben
die gesagt haben wir haben eher ein
Wärmeproblem als ein Stromproblem was im
übrigen kein Problem Mann was im übrigen
stimmt weil das Stromproblem was wir
haben kommt aus der Wärme ja und wir
haben die Diskussion auch um Brown aus
ist heute völlig unbegründet denn die
einz eine Chance dass wir oder Chance
das einzige Risiko vom Stromnetz das
einzige Risiko ein brownout in
Deutschland zu haben ist wenn die
Gasspeicher leer sind ja und das
passiert nur nach einem sehr kalten
Winter im Februar oder März
hängen sie ab ich glaube wenn wir zu der
Situation kommen die ich wie gesagt für
für überaus unwahrscheinlich halte dann
müssen wir
diskriminierungsfrei und und
der gerechteste weg ist dann alle
gleichermaßen abzuhängen ja
abgesehen natürlich von von von
Infrastruktur und von und von
Krankenhäusern und so weiter
beschäftigt sich gerade ganz konkret mit
der Frage Baden-Württemberg tut das ja
offenbar auch sonst hätte er nicht schon
die Meldung aufs Handy gegeben das heißt
das eine ganz konkrete Frage wenn wir
vorübergehend Blackout verhindern wollen
und dann eben kontrolliert runterfahren
bei wem eigentlich keinen Experte für
Netzstabilität aber ich habe gerade
heute gelesen dass das gar nicht möglich
ist irgendwie Adressen scharf
abzuschalten sondern das ist dann in der
Fläche gewissen ja in einem gewissen
Stadtteil oder möglich oder ist es nicht
möglich Sie können nicht sozialpolitisch
notfallpolitisch korrekt und scharf das
handhaben das ist in der Komplexität
unser Stromproblem kommt nicht aus dem
Wärmeproblem sondern unser Stromproblem
kommt aus der Gleichzeitigkeit von
Kernenergie Ausstieg Steinkohle Ausstieg
Braunkohle ausstieg und einseitigen
verlassen auf russischen Gas und erst
alle vier Dinge in Kombination haben das
möglich gemacht und es war mit Ansage
und es weil weil du immer wenn du nur
einen Kern Lieferanten für die
entscheidende Preis bestimmende Menge
hast und das ist falsch
mit Ansage sagen sie sind ein Mann der
Industrie was passiert eigentlich mit
Industrie mit ihrer mit ihrer mit
unserer Industrie was wird aus der
Industrie wie viele Menschen wie viele
Manager wie viel hoch dekorierte
Arbeiter kennen Sie die längst sagen das
hat hier keinen Sinn mehr in Deutschland
also ich brauche nur meine Erlebnisse in
der letzten zwei drei Tage anschauen
meine Tochter hat gestern 24 Stunden
gebraucht von Hannover nach Palma und
das hatte nichts mit dem Wetter zu tun
sondern nur mit dysfunktionalitäten bei
Lufthansa am Flughafen München und
anderen Stellen ich wollte am ich bin
England Fan wollte England Frankreich
sehen in einer Sportbar in Braunschweig
und konnte nicht mehr in Sandwich
bestellen weil die mir gesagt haben
wegen der Strompreise haben wir die
Küche zu gemacht wir sind dabei uns
aufgrund wesentlicher energiepolitischer
Fehler zu einem dysfunktionalen Land zu
entwickeln und damit verlieren wir an
dass die große Gefahr Respekt in der
Welt vieles von dem was wir sind können
und tun sind wir weil die Welt sehr viel
Respekt vor dem hat wie wir Dinge
gemacht haben und machen
also in der wenn ja aber wenn der
Ministerpräsident von Baden-Württemberg
die nicht als Person sehr schätze allen
sagt Denkmal über den Waschlappen nach
statt über die Dusche selbst in
Kambodscha und Laos sind die Menschen
heute gewohnt ein oder zweimal am Tag
übrigens auch als Menschenrecht Duschen
zu dürfen und wenn wir allen Ernstes
darüber nachdenken die Menschen zu sagen
ihr könnt nicht mehr duschen weil wir
euch die Energie nicht mehr zu
wettbewerbsfähigen Preisen zur Verfügung
stellen können nehmt lieber den
Waschlappen dann verlieren wir Respekt
in der Welt bitter böse Analyse auch der
Situation hier gerade in Deutschland wir
diskutieren gleich weiter wie wir da
rauskommen wie wir unser Stromproblem
eigentlich lösen naja ganz kurzen Pause
hier zurück
zurück bei wählt die richtigen Fragen
und wir diskutieren über unser ja immer
größer werdendes Stromproblem hier in
Deutschland haben einen Mann bei uns uns
Klassen langjährigen Energiemanager in
Deutschland der gerade bitterbös die
deutsche Situationen energiepolitisch
hier analysiert hat und gesagt hat unser
Land ist
dysfunktional wird ihm gegenüber sitzt
ein Mann er versteht Gründer von
LichtBlick der eine Roman gerade
geschrieben hat ein Krimi ein Thriller
der den jetzt auch nicht wahnsinnig
positiven Titel trägt die Welt kippt was
gibt da eigentlich gerade ja die Welt
gibt ja an verschiedenen Stellen im
Moment in meinem Buch geht es auch ums
Klima und um die Frage ob unsere
westlichen Demokratien das was wir hier
jetzt auch gerade diskutieren eigentlich
mit ihrer
langsamen Art und Weise Dinge überhaupt
auf dem Weg zu bringen in der Lage sind
ein so langfristig wirkendes Problem wie
die Klimakatastrophe bewältigen was geht
ihnen zu langsam geht ihnen zu langsam
der Entschluss die Atomkraftwerke länger
laufen zu lassen das ist ein Beispiel
von vielen ich will hier gar nicht
inhaltlich werden sondern die Politik
ist und es gar kein deutsches Phänomen
übrigens Demokratien sind heutzutage
aufgrund der Tatsache dass sie versuchen
alle möglichen partikular Interessen zu
berücksichtigen bestmöglich zu
berücksichtigen im Grunde genommen ganz
stark handlungsunfähig geworden ja und
ich will damit nicht sagen dass ich ein
Freund der Diktatur bin ganz bestimmt
natürlich nicht obwohl in meinem Roman
China dann eine ganz andere Rolle spielt
aber man muss den Finger in die Wunde
legen ja und man muss gemeinsam doch
darüber diskutieren mit den Politikern
auch als Bürger untereinander was können
wir eigentlich tun damit unser
demokratisches System das natürlich
fraglos das Beste ist was wir so langsam
aber schon mit der Sympathie bei den
Klima Klebern übrigens auch einen Tonka
direkt im Finanzministerium
vorbeigeschaut haben da plötzlich mit
der Besuchergruppe rein sind und ja
direkt neben Büro von ihrem
Finanzminister und neben ihrem standen
plötzlich auf dem Balkon waren ihre
transparente dort ausgerollt haben sie
stellen die Frage von wie weit darf man
eigentlich gehen wenn man die Welt
retten möchte das heißt diese Leute
gehen die ihnen zu weiter oder nicht ich
glaube das ist nicht eine Frage des zu
weit oder nicht ziviler Ungehorsam ist
finde ich etwas Ministerium einbrechen
hätte ich jetzt überhaupt kein Problem
zu sagen das geht mir soweit ja ich
finde sie wieder Ungehorsam so lange das
gewaltfrei bleibt ja ist was was mit
Demokratie aushalten muss das Problem
ist hier was ganz anderes die Frage ist
doch ob mit den Aktionen die hier gerade
stattfinden die Masse mitgenommen wird
er wird eigentlich die Masse mitgenommen
um wirklich eine Revolution die wir
brauchen in der Energiewirtschaft
anzustoßen Fragezeichen
anderen in ihrem Alltag behindert werden
und wenn wir das alle machen das ist ja
immer die schöne Frage Immanuel Kant was
ist wenn wir das alle machen wenn wir
alle bei unserer Meinung oder dem was
uns wichtig ist so agieren dann geht das
immer nur auf Kosten alle anderen
Menschen so kann eine Gesellschaft nicht
funktionieren deswegen bin ich in der
Tat der Meinung wir müssen Versammlungen
haben wir müssen Demonstrationen haben
wir müssen Meinungsäußerung haben aber
keine militanten Aktionen wie die die da
stattfindet das heißt die schütteln den
Kopf an der Stelle sitzen hier und das
darf ich einmal sagen haben gleichzeitig
Wohnsitz das heißt wenn hier der Strom
weg ist dann können Sie immer noch in
Großbritannien den Strom anfangen ich
schüttele deshalb den Kopf weil die
Vorschläge die einen Kollege hier macht
sind ja genau die die in der Demokratie
nicht funktioniert weil sie einfach viel
zu langsam
sind das funktioniert nicht das hat darf
ich mehr dann in der Tat werden Regeln
zerstört und ich glaube nicht dass das
funktioniert ansonsten würde ich aber
sehr davor warnen jetzt auch irgendwie
die Diktaturen zu rosig zu sehen wenn
man sich anschauen
okay corona-politik gemacht hat übrigens
mit beträchtlichen wirtschaftlichen
Schaden da können wir jetzt ganz schnell
solche ländergrunde handeln auch nicht
immer rational wir haben hier auch eine
Diktatur Erfahrung an diesem Tisch aber
noch einmal zur zu Ihnen und zu ihrer
persönlichen Lage sie sind für die
schnelleren für den schnelleren Wandel
auf dem Energiemarkt für schnellere
Anwendung zu Ökostrom sie haben auch
eine gewisse Sympathie habe ich gerade
rausgehört für diejenigen die bei ein
Tonka da im Finanzministerium
eingebrochen sind machen sie sich aber
wenn der Strom hier ausfällt aus dem
Staub und nehme mir ein Zweitwohnsitz
das mache ich natürlich nicht aber es
geht ja gar nicht darum wofür ich bin
sondern dass wir schneller handeln
müssen das ist ja Konsens ich meine das
was im Moment auf der ganzen Welt
passiert ist nicht schnell genug ja das
ist fraglos inzwischen so da bin ich ja
glücklich ja die Diskussion gibt's den
Klimawandel überhaupt und können wir uns
nicht noch 20 Jahre Zeit lassen die sind
ja verschwunden die Frage
und richtig haben will und nicht richtig
richtig
nicht mehr so Unsinn erzählen wir haben
einen Wärmeproblem aber wir haben keinen
Stromproblem und Gas hat nichts mit den
Strompreisen rationale Denken ja es gibt
keinen Politikbereich der so sehr
sachlicher logischer
Entscheidungsfindung zugänglich wäre wie
die Energiepolitik weil das ja alles
letztlich Physik ist und es gibt keinen
Bereich in dem seit 20 30 Jahren die
Rationalität jeden Tag so sehr mit Füßen
getrieben wird und wenn wir nur das
überwinden könnten wenn wir mal
pragmatisch mit dem gesunden
Menschenverstand auch in der
Energiepolitik Entscheidung treffen
könnten dann könnten wir gleichzeitig
das Richtige und auch noch Züge tun also
weniger Träumen sagen sie ich will noch
einmal ganz konkret die Frage wissen die
für Sie als nächstes ganz entscheidend
ist bei der sie eine rationale und keine
träumerische oder ihren ideologische
Antwort erwarten ich möchte nicht mehr
hören dass wir gleichzeitig Klima aus
Klimaschutz und Kernenergieausstieg in
vollem Umfang betreiben können ich
möchte nicht mehr hören das Wärme und
Strom und russisches Gas und Preise
nichts miteinander zu tun haben und wenn
wir überhaupt mal anfangen uns von
diesen Widersprüchen zu verabschieden
und einfach physikalisch unmittelbare
Widersprüche nicht mehr zu behaupten nur
weil sie in die Ideologie passen dann
können wir ab morgen eine bessere und
sinnvollere Energiepolitik machen ich
stimme überein dass wir uns werden
entscheiden müssen wie wir die
Klimaziele erreichen wollen und das kann
man mit Kohle und auch mit Gras nicht
machen und insofern braucht man neben
den Erneuerbaren auf abziehbare Zeit
komplementär was anderes und da wird
sich diese Gesellschaft mit beschäftigen
müssen wenn sie sich diesen Klimazielen
verpflichtet fühlt ich finde das sollte
sie tun wenn Herr Klassen das so
eindringlich sagt und sie im im
weitesten Recht geben haben sie trotzdem
hinter dem Hinterkopf wir regieren ja
gerade in der Amt das heißt doch nicht
das heißt doch nicht dass man aufhört
selbst zu denken es war ja auch die FDP
die die Laufzeiten verlängert hat wir
haben übrigens auch durchgesetzt dass
die europäischen Autos auch künftig noch
mit Klima neutralen Kraftstoffen
gefahren werden
damit das nicht nur mit Strom passieren
soll das ist aber
national das ist doch genau wo wir
gerade gesprochen im Kernkraft Problem
bleiben da sagen sie erstmal dann wäre
dafür gesorgt dass das
gelöst ist erstmal über den Winter und
so weiter das Problem kommt wieder auf
dem Tisch haben sie schon Brennelemente
bestellt oder wann müssen Sie die
bestellen wir haben natürlich noch keine
Brennelemente bestellt weil sie genau
wissen dass wir bis zum 16 April die
Laufzeiten jetzt vereinbart haben genau
das ist aber jetzt über den Winter
hinweg die ähm auch der Januar der
Februar der März werden diese Kraftwerke
weiter zur Verfügung stehen und dann am
16 ist wir werden uns noch mal anschauen
wie der Winter gelaufen
sie wissen genau dass ich auch so
längeren Lauf
klar man kann anderer Meinung sein ich
will aber von Herrn Tonka wissen wann er
damit anfängt der wird nicht warten bis
zum 16 der hat seinen Plan schon in der
Tasche wieder vorliegt
wir haben jetzt eine Regelung getroffen
die war die war politisch nicht leicht
zu erreichen aber sie hilft uns selbst
abgewischt und da das nächste wie geht's
weiter wann knallen sie das den Grünen
wieder von den Leuten Knall den Grünen
gar nichts vor dem Latz sondern wir
schauen uns an wie sich jetzt die
Stromversorgung aber vom Anschauen wird
sich nicht ändern vor 15 Jahren gesagt
wir dürfen wir müssen in eine globale
solare Energiewirtschaft da gibt es gar
keinen Zweifel ja wir dürfen es aber
nicht tun indem wir temporär fossile
Energien zementieren wie spielt
Steinkohle oder jetzt russisches Gas wir
müssen es tun indem wir Energieeffizienz
erhöhen und indem wir in der Lage sind
die Sonnenenergie aus den Regionen wo
sie anfällt Sahara Mojave Wüste Kalahari
dahin zu bringen wo sie gebraucht wird
und in den 15 Jahren ist nichts getan um
dafür die nicht die die die die die
Grenzen übergreifenden Netzstrukturen zu
schaffen das hätte man alles tun können
und damit müssen wir im Grunde morgen
beginnen das heißt wir müssen zwei
gleichzeitig arbeiten Wissen über den
Winter kommen in einer
sozialverträglichen Form und das ist
Aufgabe nicht nur der Energiepolitik
sondern der sozial und für skalpolitik
und wir müssen in der Energiepolitik
morgen anfangen wirklich logisch
vernünftig aus dem was wir wollen die
entsprechenden Maßnahmen herzzuleiten
den Kopf geschildert und tief geatmet
immer wieder warum ja also erstmal
müssen wir aus dieser komischen
Scheindebatte raus Atomkraft ist fertig
in Deutschland Punkt aus und wer das
nicht akzeptiert der der verkennt der
Realitäten es wird keine Atomkraft bei
uns mehr geben die Leute wollen das
nicht wir sind die die Bevölkerung die
meint der Großteil der Bevölkerung ist
gegen gerade was ganz anderes es gab
diese Jahre als der Atomausstieg nämlich
beschlossen wurde aber die Stimmung
genauso wie sie geschildert haben
wir hätten eine Stromlücke und dafür
wollen sie dafür noch die Atomkraft
haben und dann sagen die Leute ja für
die stromlöcke wenn sie denn da ist aber
die Stromlücke die wir tatsächlich haben
wenn wir sie denn haben ich glaube auch
halt irgendwelche Braunau zu oder
Blackouts die kommen glaube ich nicht
weil ich unterhalte mich ja auch mit den
Energieversorgungen keine Atomkraft
wollen sie Kohlekraft diese Problematik
mit der Atomkraft ist doch die wir
brauchen gerade so viel Strom weil
Frankreich so viel Atomkraftwerke hat
und die laufen nicht die laufen nicht
weil es bei uns immer zu trocken und zu
heiß wird und dann diese Dinger nicht
mehr gekühlt werden können französische
Atomkraft hat bisher die deutschen
Strompreise runtergeladen
ist hier wieder das Hauptproblem noch
die Lösung dass der entscheidende Punkt
ist dass wir im Bereich des Ausbaus der
erneuerbaren Energien Dinge gemacht
haben die zum Teil ineffizient waren die
zum Teil
Spekulationsgewinne erzeugt haben
Privatisierung von Gewinnen
Sozialisierung von Verlusten und dass
wir im Bereich der globalen solaren
Strukturen von denen wir profitieren
könnten grenzübergreifen nichts getan
haben also nein
bei mir wunderbar Sonne Empfang war
alles ineffizient für vergleichen
gegangen gehen Sie mal nach Hannover und
schauen Sie sich das Wetter an dann
verstehen Sie den Unterschied aber
lassen da danke klar lassen Sie mich das
bitte noch einmal unterstreichen was
vorbei Klassen gerade gesagt haben die
Atomenergie Diskussion ist völlig
sinnlos sie ist völlig sinnlos wir
können über eine Verlängerung sprechen
das ist mir egal ja weil wir Ideologie
frei diskutieren müssen das löst aber
überhaupt kein Problem ja wenn wir neue
wenn wir neue Atomkraftwerke bauen
würden ja wäre das ein Weg den man
diskutieren könnte aber das findet nicht
statt das wird auch nie stattfinden
relativ lange es dauert nicht relativ
lange es dauert 20 Jahre bis sie neues
Atomkraftwerk am Netz haben und bis
dahin sind die Erneuerbaren so weit
vorne
ist Atomkraft die teuerste Energie die
man sich vorstellen kann teurer als
erneuerbare sowieso teurer als Kohle und
sogar teurer als Gast aber sicher
sauber ganz bestimmt nicht sicher aber
das ist wieder eine persönliche Meinung
aber sicher gar nicht bemühen sicher mit
Blick auf meinen sie im Sinne von ja
lecker ja aber sie ist sie ist wenn Sie
wenn Sie die Kosten einer Solaranlage
und eines Windrads inklusive Speicher
Backup um zuverlässig über das ganze
Jahr den Strom zur Versorgung zur
Verfügung stellen zu können die Kosten
vergleichen mit einem Atomkraftwerk ist
das Atomkraftwerk mehr als doppelt so
teuer ein neu gebaut ist deshalb ist die
Diskussion völlig sinnlos die muss nicht
mehr geführt werden
es geht also ich glaube auch nicht dass
in Deutschland momentan eine Diskussion
geführt wird über den groß angelegten
Wiedereinstieg sondern die Diskussion
dreht sich um die Frage ob man in einer
Energiekrise die noch nicht komplett
unter Kontrolle ist alle technologischen
Optionen nutzt oder sich zumindest
aufrecht erhält oder nicht und ich
befürchte und ich bedauere sehe das
offensichtlich die Antwort jetzt auf der
kurze unserer Ansicht in Deutschland
mehr Kohle heißt denn wir dürfen ja
nicht immer nur die Schwächen jeder
Energie thematisieren wir müssen ja auch
sehen dass wir mit der Entscheidung
gegen die eine eine Entscheidung für
eine andere Technologie treffen und das
ist in dem Fall die fossile Kohle und
und wenn wir all das Hören der Klassen
ist ihr Eindruck ihr Wissen dass in den
nächsten Jahren auch so wie wir mit die
Politik erleben unser Stromproblem in
Deutschland kleiner wird oder eher
größer wird es wird größer wenn wir
nicht von der Ideologisierung wegkommen
erlauben Sie mir zwei Sätze zu kennen
Energie ich selbst habe vor 15 Jahren
vorgeschlagen als Chef eines großen
Energiekonzerns den Kernenergie Ausstieg
in der Verfassung fest zu schreiben ich
bin kein Kernenergie Lobbyist oder
Fetisch ist aber wenn wir sagen der
Klimawandel ist das größte Problem was
die Menschheit hat dann ist jede Tonne
und jedes Gramm vermieten das CO2
wichtig und dann ist jeder Monat in ein
kernkraftwerkleiter laufen kann wichtig
und wenn wir sagen das soziale Problem
der Strompreise im Winter kann vital
werden dann ist läuft auch da jede
kostenseitige Entlastung die wir haben
können wichtig und weil die bestehenden
kraftkernkraftwerke ja im Grunde
abgeschrieben sind ist natürlich das
auch ein Entlastendes Element um nicht
die preissteigernden Effekte des
ausbleibenden russischen Gases zu sozial
unverträglich werden zu lassen unser
Stromproblem wird erstmal offenbar nicht
kleiner sondern größer freien Käfer
rechnen Sie damit dass die Preise auch
weiter steigen oder zumindest auf
absehbare Sicht nicht sinken werden wir
in der Politik so weitermachen ist wird
das wahrscheinlich der Fall sein wenn
wir uns gegenseitig zerstreiten und
immer nur über Allgemeinheiten reden
über Erwägungen ich frage mich ganz
konkret wann kommt die übergewinnsteuer
die sicherstellt dass wir hier keine
Wind voll
Profession
eingesetzt wird wir brauchen die
zeitenwände auch auf dem Energiemarkt
und das war muss diese Zeitenwende
sozialver
dazu brauchen wir die übergewinnsteuer
dazu brauchen wir das Geld das ist ja
ein Fehler hier so etwas überhaupt
zuzulassen in dieser Woche eine Erlös
Abschöpfung heißt das wo sehr sehr hohe
Maßen von einzelnen Stromerzeugern
abgeschöpft werden aber nicht in den äh
zum Finanzminister gehen wie eine Steuer
sondern direkt im Strommarkt bleiben bei
den Netzbetreibern und dann in
niedrigere Strompreise umgesetzt werden
also das ist genau
Verteilungskampf auch auf dem
Energiemarkt und dann müssen wir die
soziale Seite sehen
ihre Kunden Verbraucherzentrale Fragen
ja ist es jetzt nur vorübergehend vor
ballot oder wird es so bleiben was sagen
sie denn also die Preise werden bisschen
wieder runter gehen sie werden nicht auf
das vor ich will nicht sagen vor kriegst
Niveau sondern auf das 2020er Niveau
zurückgehen definitiv nicht sie werden
weiter oben bleiben und ich hoffe
einfach mal dass wir von diesem ganzen
komischen bremsen und den ganzen Kram
wegkommt der jetzt hier auf die Schnelle
irgendwie geschossen wird dass das
Finanzministerium zum Beispiel endlich
mal die Voraussetzung schafft dass wir
tatsächlich gezielter Gelder den Leuten
zukommen lassen können dies brauchen
dann können wir uns dieses ganze Trara
sparen hier mit diesen Abrechnungen mit
diesen ganzen Rattenschwanz da hinten
dran hängt und ich möchte natürlich auch
dass wir haben jetzt ganz viele
Wärmepumpen gefördert und eingebaut und
wenn sie die mit 40 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde sozusagen betreiben
sollen das geht nicht da muss auch noch
was kommen irgendwie
in der Runde der Lichtblick gegründet
hat und den Blick auch in seinem Roman
in die Zukunft wirft was ist der
Strompreis bei dem sie glücklich sind
sie haben zu Beginn der Sendung gesagt
ich bin ein ganz happy das Strom
fertiger geworden ist auch teurer
geworden ist weil wegen Strompreis sind
sie happy und wo endet die Reise er ist
im Moment zu hoch gar keine Frage er war
in der Vergangenheit zu niedrig also
irgendwo dazwischen wäre
am liebsten weil dann die Leute und auch
die auch das Gewerbe und auch die
Industrie
behutsam damit umgehen werden und da
kommen wir auch hin also Strom ist ja
ein börsenprodukt sie können heute schon
sehen was der Strom in zwei drei vier
fünf sechs Jahren kostet und wir sind im
Moment in dem Peak und das geht wieder
stark nach unten und wenn wir 100%
erneuerbar sind wird der Strom ganz
billig ja im Moment sind wir bei einem
paar kleinen Prozentchen ein ganz weiter
weg diese Sendung hat mich immer nur Mut
gemacht muss ganz ehrlich zugeben das
letzte Wort aber der Strompreis wird
wieder etwas sinken ja ihr Wort in
Gottes Wort danke Ihnen für diese
Diskussion in dieser Sendung bis
nächsten Montag
[Musik]